what's more evil demons attacking people
and sending them to hell or human beings
trying to use the fear of those demons
to control others that question and
crazy premise is at the heart of
hellbound netflix's latest offering of
south korean horror
i would like to welcome you all
to the new world
faith and fear are at the heart of
hellbound the show begins with an
unimaginable premise seemingly ordinary
people are visited by a supernatural
apparition who tells them that they have
been marked for death and will be taken
to hell at a certain date and time when
the said time arrives a team of demons
emerges from the ether and violently
incinerates the victim you know they say
it's some kind of warning to everyone
two separate religious movements claim
that those who receive the decree are
sinners and that the condemnations are
an act of god who is trying to show
humanity the true path of righteousness
the new true society works to make sure
the public is aware of what is going on
by trying to document and broadcast the
supernatural events meanwhile the
arrowhead is a fanatic and violent cult
who believes god is pointing out the
sinners and wants his followers to take
matters into their own hands
but midway through the six episode
season there's a shocking revelation
chairman jung jin soo the leader of the
new true society admits that he knew
about the demons before the rest of
humanity because he had been marked for
death 20 years before the events of the
show it was he who invented the notion
that the decrees are handed down to
sinners because he was afraid that if
humanity had no reasoning for the events
it would drive them to chaos he takes
that secret to the grave and the new
truth society grows in popularity
however years in the future a child is
born that threatens to upend the vice
grip they have on society welcome to
hell
as hell bound season one kareem's toward
its conclusion the attention of most of
the main players has turned to the
newborn baby of a skeptical tv producer
named bae youngjae and his wife song so
young shortly after the child is born it
receives the decree that it will be
taken to hell on top of being
devastating news to the parents this is
a serious blow to the new truth society
it can happen to any one of us it's not
about punishing or about being punished
your baby is innocent as men hey jin an
attorney who has long worked to expose
the group as a fraud notes the new true
society's doctrine does not include the
concept of original sin they have
convinced their followers that only
those who have actively committed sins
in their life are given the decree if
their followers were to see a newborn
taken to hell it would prove what
chairman jungjian tsu tried to hide
which is that the decrees are actually
being passed out seemingly at random
this is why men hey jan wants the
parents to live stream the moment that
their baby is taken to hell if you
decide to let us broadcast this
demonstration the baby will save the
world unlike some other similar shows
about religious phenomena hellbound
makes it very clear from the beginning
that there are supernatural forces at
play there's no question that people are
being horrifically killed by smoke
demons but nobody actually knows what
the demons are or why they chose the
people they chose the new true society
and the arrowhead who are not officially
linked but often secretly collaborate
use the idea that the demons only come
for sinners to try and control society
their assumed morality also allows them
to violently silence non-believers that
is why when both groups find out about
the newborn baby that is marked for hell
each tries to stop the public from
finding out
although both the new truth society and
the arrowhead try to find the condemned
child they aren't able to intervene in
time song so young brings her baby into
the courtyard of an apartment building
and asks the residents there to witness
the child being taken to hell however
when the demons actually arrive neither
parent can face the [ __ ] of watching
their baby be tormented and killed they
hug the infant between them as the
demons descend and when the family is
zapped both parents are incinerated but
the baby is left unharmed this is a very
profound moment as up until now we've
never seen a case where the decree
wasn't fulfilled that isn't lost on the
character known as skull mask an
extremely zealous livestreamer who once
acted as the de facto leader of the
arrowhead but why is the new truth not
disclosing who the sinner is and what
that sinner did to deserve to go to hell
huh what do you think my friends he
arrives on the scene having received a
decree that he will be taken to hell
shortly after the baby with some
influence from the new true society he's
interpreted that the baby's condemnation
is a mistake and that he's been chosen
by god to correct the error by keeping
anyone from seeing as the baby is sent
to hell when he sees that the child is
still alive he tries to kill it in a bit
of confusion but minheijin manages to
hold skull mask off until the demons
come and take him to hell all of this
chaos has a pretty serious effect on the
assembled crowd everything they've just
seen flies in the face of what they've
been told by the religious groups who
claim to understand what's going on when
representatives in the new true society
show up and try to follow men hey gin as
she flees with the baby the crowd
refuses to let them through and calls
the church members pathetic crooks and a
bunch of liars that's enough
you're a bunch of liars
seeing the crowd turn on the new true
society is a major moment as the church
has up until that point wielded a huge
amount of social and political power but
now that the world has seen that their
doctrine is false it appears that their
power is doomed to crumble away after
escaping men hey jin and the baby
managed to hail a cab at which point the
taxi driver offers his thoughts about
the crisis everyone is facing in a
refreshing contrast to the show's many
false prophets he bluntly says he
doesn't know much about god and he
doesn't care either there's one thing i
do know and that is that this world
belongs to humans
we should settle our matters ourselves
don't you agree misman this statement is
in many ways a perfectly succinct
summarization of the main thematic
threads of hellbound although the demons
are a terrifying violent force it isn't
something humanity actually has any
control over this is a horrible prospect
but is one that is made significantly
worse by the new true society and the
arrowhead both groups seized on a moment
when humanity was facing extreme fear
and confusion and used it to gain an
outsized amount of influence the new
true society in particular actively
worked to hide the fact that they knew
their own doctrine was false they
claimed that they wanted to help society
by showing everyone god's plan but the
reality is they wanted to scare people
into believing they had all the answers
so they could wield power over them
think of them like a preacher who claims
that a deadly hurricane is god's
punishment for humanity's sins the taxi
driver's remarks get at the heart of
what hellbound is trying to say it's not
asking viewers to disbelieve in the
supernatural rather it's asking us to
remain skeptical of those who manipulate
our fears of the supernatural to try and
exert power over others
the ending of hellbound is a classic
good news bad news situation the good
news is that min hey jin has struck a
major blow against the new true society
the bad news is that we've gotten no
closer to understanding what the demons
are or how to stop them in the episode's
final moments we also learned that there
are more to the decrees than we
previously knew the finale ends in the
museum dedicated to park jungja a woman
who was taken by the demons during a
live television broadcast that helped
the new truth society prove their claims
the house she was taken in has been
preserved along with her charred remains
which are kept under a plexiglas case as
the camera zooms in on her skeleton it
begins to shake and after a few intense
moments park chung-jaw is re-animated
and seemingly brought back to life this
cliffhanger implies that there are plans
for another season of hellbound and it
also hints at what that season may
explore while season 1 focused on the
human response to the arrival of the
demons we don't actually learn much
about the phenomenon itself by
introducing this new wrinkle to the
process that those condemned to hell may
eventually be resurrected the show is
perhaps indicating that if there is a
season two we might be digging deeper
into the actual mythology of the demons
themselves why was park jungja
resurrected what will she have to say
about what she experienced and while
we're at it why was the baby spared by
the demons we'll just have to hope that
netflix brings back hellbound for a
second season so we can get those
answers i'm so happy i can hardly wait
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]